[Applause]  we wanted to help those who are affected  by gun violence the mayor's office the  VA see makes sure that this money is  responsibly sourced that those who have  been affected by gun violence this is an  authentic genuine contribution to the  City of Jacksonville and I don't know if  we are still on the air but I'll say  this you can't counter program what all  the elite wrestling is doing perhaps you  could counter program me perhaps you  good counter program Nick or brandy but  guess what you cannot counter program  the love the genuine feeling  I have one question when this group goes  to TNT this fall let me ask each and  every one of you who are you coming with  us  [Applause]